[Musique]
invités devaient y paie aujourd'hui
laurent mazaury bonjour bonjour
bienvenue en plateau homme politique élu
à elancourt adjoint au maire délégué à
la culture vous siégez à l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines en tant que
vice président chargé des sports vous
avez aussi parmi vos différentes
fonctions de la présidence de la société
la d'exploitation mixte repart donc
d'ici mais cette style en cours et puis
celle de cette chaîne aussi de tv 78 et
il ya un point commun à toutes ces
casquettes elles sont fortement
impactées par la crise sanitaire plus
théâtre plus de cinéma a plus de culture
plus de sport non plus peut-être un
sentiment général au début
est ce que vous avez peur pour l'avenir
de ces secteurs qu'ils aient du mal à se
relever alors certains plus que d'autres
d'abord merci de m'accueillir j'allais
dire chez nous mon cher wilfried
certains plus que d'autres
bien entendu il se sera probablement
beaucoup plus difficile pour les
activités culturelles que pour les
activités sportives
même si nos associations souffrent
évidemment énormément à la fois de
l'absence des adhérents mais aussi de
l'absence des bénévoles est un des
points majeurs pour les associations
sportives c'est de conserver sa sera de
renouveler les bénévoles parce que
rapidement les bénévoles bien vont
passer à autre chose et il risque de ne
plus être là et sur l'activité
culturelle alors on n'a pas totalement
tout stopper en 30 l'école municipale de
danse de sport d'arts plastiques
continue à délivrer une prestation
évidemment essentiellement digital mais
par contre et bien sûr les salles
culturelles publiques seront frappés la
même façon que les salles culturelles
privées à une différence près c'est que
malheureusement ou heureusement on n'a
pas une obligation de résultat de
chiffre d'affaires en obligation de bien
dépenser dans l'intérêt général de
déniers publics et bien entendu les
différentes collectivités qui nous
soutiennent entre autres la mairie
d'elancourt pour la structure culturelle
élan courtois sera toujours présente
oui ça veut dire que justement vous qui
êtes aussi responsable politique y aura
un accompagnement on peut penser que ce
sera pas forcément les secteurs
prioritaires pour relancer la machine
économique
il ya bien entendu un accompagnement il
ya déjà un accompagnement il y aura mais
il y à déjà on n'est ce pas les
associations seul et on laisse pas nos
structures culturelles à l'abandon n'est
ce pas notre cinéma non plus à l'abandon
mais bien sûr il faudra soutenir cette
relance l'état y est aussi également
pour beaucoup mais faudra le soutenir
par des éléments et des décisions
concrètes du quotidien c'est pas
forcément que de l'argent c'est d'être
là ne serait-ce que psychologiquement
pour épauler les différentes personnes
que tu vas pouvoir reprendre ses
activités
si on parle du cinéma plus
spécifiquement du ciné cette aile en
cours
comment vous voyez l'avenir du cinéma
parce qu'il ya plein de questions qui se
posent des cinémas sont fermées
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les
distributeurs ont pris d'autres
habitudes ils diffusent sur des
plateformes on peut citer disney par
exemple qui diffuse maintenant
uniquement ses films sur sa plateforme
de streaming
ça veut dire qu'il faut repenser le
cinéma mais mais le repenser comment
alors c'est certainement pas moi qui
humblement vais repenser de cinéma en
tout cas de réflexion vous avez avec les
salariés de la structure
alors d'abord on continue à croire au
cinéma parce que c'est un lieu social
c'est un lieu de rencontre et puis la
loi pour l'instant nous protège encore
la loi le prévoit toujours en france à
sa nombre d'éléments liés à la
production et la création
cinématographique qui permet une
redistribution dans les salles qui
permet de soutenir le fonctionnement de
nos salles ensuite les spectateurs sur
notre meilleure garantie quand je vois
les témoignages poignants que nous avons
entre autres sur des réseaux sociaux
pour le signer cette d'un grand nombre
de nos spectateurs qui sont fidèles qui
viennent par passion delà du peu du
grand écran et de la salle noire et du
fait de regarder ensemble un film moi je
reste résolument optimiste sur le fait
que à la fois les spectateurs
reviendrons mais la programmation
reviendra je ne suis pas certain mais
frites que la décision d'aller vers les
plateformes sur une décision qui soit
unique monolithique définitive et qui
fasse que 100% des films demain seront
exclusivement produite et distribuée par
les plateformes les plateformes c'est un
autre mode de distribution qui pour moi
est complémentaire de suite du cinéma
mais le cinéma vous le verrez perdurera
on avait dit exactement la même chose
que la télévision est né dans un premier
temps pour la radio est arrivé un peu
après le cinéma puis la télévision dadis
et la mort des salles et on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui le cinéma est plus
vivant que jamais en tout cas à part le
vide et je suis certain qu'il en est
rapidement de ses cendres très
temporaire donc le signer cette aile en
cours va perdurer et va se relever une
nouvelle fois on peut rappeler que tout
même ce cinéma existe depuis 1975 qu'il
a fait face à de nombreuses périodes
difficiles génération des multiplexes
par exemple il a fallu se se réinventer
sur moderniser c'était en 2013 et
aujourd'hui forcément survivants suite à
cette cette crise cette crise sanitaire
je tiens à dire d'ailleurs que les
années se suivent et ne se ressemblent
pas puisque le ciné 7 en 2019 a connu sa
plus forte fréquentation depuis son
origine
avec plus de 110 mille entrées c'était
son plus gros chiffres et voyez nous
connaîtrons l'année suivante la pire
fréquentation puisque évidemment nous
sommes paisiblement aujourd'hui à 30
mille entrées mais on voit néanmoins que
dans un système de fonctionnement normal
les spectateurs sont bien au rendez vous
pour nous soutenir
on parle de la culture on parle du sport
aussi pour l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines je le disais tout à
l'heure vous êtes le vice président en
charge donc du sport en 2024 il y aura
les jeux olympiques les jeux
paralympiques également il y a cinq
épreuves olympiques cyclisme sur piste
bmx golf vtt épreuves d'escrimé
également du pentathlon moderne et puis
une épreuve paralympiques ce sera le
cyclisme sur piste saint quentin en
yvelines
l'agglomération est prête pour 2024
allait évidemment à la fois
psychologiquement prête et puis elle a
quasiment tous ses équipements à
l'exception d'accueil d'elancourt qui
sont déjà disponibles il avait été prévu
préparé pour ça certains ont même été
testé un jeu rappelle les championnats
du monde sur piste pour le vélodrome
nationale et puis bien évidemment la
ryder cup au golf national donc plus
près que saint quentin en yvelines
je ne vois pas d'autres communes qui le
soit je dirais même qu'on est presque
beaucoup plus prêt que paris lui même en
tant que tel nous sommes probablement la
ville qui est déjà la plus olympique il
a plu par un épique de france avec nos
équipements mais également avec la
mentalité on a pu tester avec des riders
cup l'importance que revêtait le fait
d'impliquer à la fois la population faut
pas que ce soit un événement extérieur
qui viennent et un peu comme un criquet
qui mange un chant qui repartent ensuite
c'est pour ça que nous travaillons avec
la population sur ce qu'on appelle
l'héritage c'est à dire que faire de nos
structures au lendemain des jeux
olympiques et que le geste d'accueil des
jeux olympiques à part l'élément de
motivation de centralité de dynamisme
également pour nos entreprises soient
aussi un élément structurant
d'équipements destinés à durer
d'équipements de transport d'équipements
d'accueil des sports est évidemment bien
entendu d'équipement au service aussi
nos entreprises donc on est prêt mais on
est prêt aussi pour le lendemain des
jeux olympiques des jeux olympiques ne
s'arrête pas de 1024 à 50 en est la
situation aujourd'hui sanitaire qui
entraient une crime qui entraîne une
crise économique n'aura pas d'incidence
sur ces jo 2024 écoutez je vais même
vous dire qu'on pourrait prendre à côté
positif entre autres le report des jeux
olympiques de tokyo l'année dernière à
cette année à 2021 qui s'annonce ce qui
nous permet entre guillemets de gagner
un an sur l'expérience
l'analyse des décisions techniques à
prendre et à regarder ces jeux
olympiques de tokyo pour adapter
éventuellement certains nos équipements
mieux définir par exemple nos pistes de
bmx mieux définir par exemple encore la
future
coline d'elancourt avec sa piste de vtt
donc il y aura pas d'impact
je pense que d'ici là le vaccin nous
aura je l'espère protéger sauver tous
j'espère également qu'il y aura des
traitements parce qu'on parle beaucoup
du vaccin faut pas oublier quand même
traitement ça me semble à mon sens moi
j'ai été touché parce que j'ai donné mon
papa de jeu voilà je pense que les
traitements sont vraiment essentiel et
c'est probablement quand même quelque
chose qui pour les jeux olympiques de
2024 nous apprendra à mieux répartir les
foules à mieux les gérer au mieux les
accueillir à être encore plus humain si
on peut l'être dans l'accueil des
populations sur les différents sites
olympiques à 50 en une et bien vous
parliez de l'héritage il faut aussi que
la population s'approprie ces jeux
olympiques avant même qu in des lieux et
il y aura des opérations peut-être je
pense à la journée olympique c'est le 23
juin en 2020 ce n'a pas pu avoir lieu en
2021 par contre il y aura bien une
journée olympique on l'espère absolument
après absolument on y travaille elle est
budgétée c'est prévu et puis il y aura
dans l'ensemble des communes bien
entendu un chèque directement d'un
village olympique qui sera dressée à
chaque fois que nécessaire ces
manifestations et comme on l'avait fait
pour la ryder cup il y aura bien entendu
un énorme travail réalisé avec les
scolaires aussi mais aussi avec les
entreprises mais je ne veux pas le dire
aujourd'hui j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir que vous en parlez ont réservé
un centre de surprises aux sportives
d'éléments majeurs et qui je l'espère de
la non des éléments récurrents sur le
territoire on va profiter à présent de
cette émission pour parler un petit peu
de tv 78 notre chaîne pour ceux qui nous
qui nous suivent
je disais tout à l'heure en introduction
que vous en êtes le président alors je
vais donner quelques précisions pour les
téléspectateurs c'est une société
d'économie mixte elle associe des
financeurs publics des financeurs privés
qui se retrouvent au sein d'un conseil
d'administration qui sont auprès au sein
de ce conseil d'administration il ya des
représentants notamment politiques de
tous bords qui sont présents à sa
création 92 tv fils à l'époque tv fil 78
ne couvrait que le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus le cas vous pouvez le voir au
quotidien nous couvrons quasiment
l'intégralité du département mais
quelles sont les perspectives un petit
peu de développement pour cette chaîne
alors ils sont extraordinaires le
premier point vous avez raison nous
couvrons tout le département marité nous
pouvons le monde entier puisque nous
sommes disponibles d'un point de vue
digitale ce qui est quand même assez
important et puis nous sommes également
disponible sur le film et sur l'ensemble
des boks sur la firme à l'ensemble des
peuples ça c'est important mais
journalistique mans vous avez raison
nous nous sommes
anisé l'année dernière et sous votre
houlette et chiens vous en remercier ici
wilfried et avec l'aide de patrice
carmouze maintenant également pour avoir
une cour des couvertures sur nice tic de
l'ensemble du département des yvelines
donc le premier enjeu pour nous c'est de
d'assoir de structurer définitivement la
couverture du département d'être présent
partout où il ya besoin que nous soyons
pour remonter des informations mais
également pour montrer tout ce qui se
fait de positif est le deuxième point
c'est effectivement cette révolution de
ton c'est à dire que nous sommes une
télévision samedi devant la presse que
des régionales nous sommes et grâce à
vous nous sommes présents tous les jours
sur le terrain
nous remontons des informations et il
faut que nous travaillons à montrer tous
les attraits cas bien entendu à 50 ans
les villes mais qui a également le
département des yvelines par rapport au
reste des autres départements français a
montré ce qui s'y fait du bien je n'aime
pas pratiquer les anglicismes et je
dirais les best practice
quels sont les éléments motivants
j'allume ma télévision je vais savoir ce
qui se passe à côté de chez moi
mais éventuellement bien sûr on va
parler des problèmes on va continuer à
le faire entre autres pendant le journal
on va montrer les difficultés mais on va
toujours les montrer en important des
propositions de solutions et en montrant
tout ce que les habitants les
entreprises les élus de ce territoire
font de positif au service du plus grand
nombre
nous sommes une fenêtre ouverte sur les
evil mais une fenêtre qu'on a envie
d'ouvrir pour prendre un bol d'air pour
savoir ce qui se passe et pour
résolument être tournés vers un avenir
j'allais dire adieu ou en tout cas et on
le voit bien avec le confinement
aujourd'hui et on a vu d'ailleurs le
taux de fréquentation sur les dinos
différents supports qui a été hâtivement
extraordinaire et pourquoi fait-il des
téléspectateurs pour voir un petit peu
plus il serait approprié le local en
quelque sorte consommer local consommer
local d'information aussi et on vous en
remercie pour voir un peu ce qui se
passa à côté de chez soi juste ou même
il ya eu de nombreuses télévisions
locales ces dernières années qui ont
disparu manque de financement ça semble
pas être le cas pour notre chaîne
les perspectives sont plutôt bonnes pour
le développement ont indiqué des
inquiétudes à avoir comme mais c'est
inquiétant aussi pour la pluralité des
médias au sien alors il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas d'inquiétude à avoir sauf à ce que
personne n'aurait pu prédire le codi de
gaubiving donc demain et pour l'heure un
astéroïde qui nous tombe dessus et où
quelqu'un n'avait pas de sujet à part
cela c'est une boutade
enfin bon comme toujours à présent à
l'esprit que nous utilisons de l'argent
public et que cet argent public il faut
la louer en fonction bien entendu de
l'intérêt général
à ce stade il n'y a pas du tout
d'inquiétude je dirais même qu'il y a
que des éléments qui doit nous rassurer
premièrement nous travaillons à ce que
le conseil départemental diw rejoint le
panel d'actionnaires dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure
qui dit conseil départemental des idées
dit d'abord une marque de confiance et
dit bien entendu des financements qui
nous donne déjà d'ailleurs en partie
j'étais hier soir en conseil
communautaire les délibérations qui
viennent nous soutenir sont votés à
l'unanimité
et je tiens ici à saluer d'ailleurs la
responsabilité des différents élus du
territoire et vous l'avez dit wilfried
qu'ils soient de droite de gauche ou du
centre
ils soutiennent notre chaîne parce que
je crois qu'ils ont bien conclu
aujourd'hui la chance qui était une
chaîne locale comme tv soixante dix huit
pour porter la parole d'un territoire et
mitre et tous les attraits de la vie
quotidienne sur territoire dont moi je
n'ai pas de motif d'inquiétude
j'ai que des motifs d'optimisme et je
pense que notre cette nouvelle mandature
sera au contraire celle qui s'ouvrira
pour porter encore plus haut la parole
de tv 78 et donc des territoires que
vous représentez quand vous prenez la
parole wilfried nouvelle mandature
puisque vous venez effectivement d'être
réélu président de cette chaîne
peut-être un mot aussi rapidement sur
l'évolution de la télévision et ça ne
concerne pas uniquement la télévision
nationale les télévisions locales aussi
sont concernés
il ya un autre mode de consommation par
les smartphones et tablettes site
internet les replays il faut repenser
tout ça il ya des perspectives de
développement dans ce sens aussi
alors déjà on a repris il faut repenser
la mise en images la mise en son le
packaging du transfert de nos
différentes émissions c'est déjà
commencer je crois qu'on s'y atteler
sous votre houlette et souha élève de
thierry barbé lettre au directeur
général ménard efficace les community
managers le différend webmasters qui
sont dans cette chaîne ou sur cette
capacité cette volonté on le voit
quotidien d'adapter nos messages aux
différents supports et vous avez raison
il reste encore des choses à inventer
entre autres en termes d'interactivité
quelque chose qu'on ne fait probablement
pas assez qu'on va développer
c'est à dire faire
intervenir le télé ça alors je veux dire
le téléspectateur mais le consommateur
de nos images qui aujourd'hui peut
intervenir grâce effectivement à
l'ensemble du digital et au retour qu'on
peut en avoir
c'est un point sur lequel nous allons
travailler effectivement de manière très
forte dans les mois et les années à
venir
dernier mot dernière question principale
projet pour vous sur cette mandature
pour tv 78 je voulais d'y consolider ces
financements accroître son audience
puisque on existe la sphère l'audience
également un point important nous sommes
un des rares vecteurs de publicité
locale avec l'affichage finistère
éventuellement et nous devons vraiment
nous renforcer sur cet aspect là parce
que quand on fait de la publicité locale
certes ou fait rentrer des recettes mais
également on montre au palais tous les
commerces de proximité qui en ont tant
besoin aujourd'hui on montra très notre
chaîne tout l'important c'est toute la
couverture l'extraordinaire
pluridisciplinarité de ces commerces
notre territoire
donc nous devons également développer
nos ressources publicitaires delà des
ressources surtout la visibilité nos
commerçants et nos différents commerces
sur notre chaîne
ça aussi c'est un enjeu merci beaucoup
l'euro mazaury et puis je vais en
profiter aussi pour remercier toutes les
équipes avec qui nous travaillons au
quotidien et qui vous permettent de
suivre ses programmes
voilà à très bientôt à trégunc très
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
à